if we don't pick our parents we don't
pick our siblings our uncle our grandma
all of us we pick our friends yeah and
they always start off as strangers
remember this strangers become
acquaintances acquaintances become
friends and Friends become family and I
really believe in that Journey like we
don't pick our parents we don't pick our
siblings our uncle our grandma all of us
we pick our friends yeah and they always
start off as strangers yeah and so be
more open don't be scared love yourself
give yourself some Freedom don't beat
yourself up love yourself because if you
love yourself you'll have room to love
others and that's what we're saying